this goby fish in Hawaii can climb up
300-foot waterfalls and physics students
from the University of Leicester have
determined that because of the Doppler
effect hyperspace travel would really
look like this
Vsauce Kevin here this is mine a
clothing store in Japan has a hangar
system that displays video of a model
wearing the clothes you removed from the
rack the hangers have simple on-off
switches depending on if the article of
clothing is hanging or is picked up and
each have a unique ID that is tied to a
PC in the back which displays a photo or
video of the model wearing that piece of
clothing it's kind of a digital take on
mannequins but it's really more of a
novelty and try to get online shoppers
back into brick-and-mortar stores these
LED ice cubes let you know when you've
had too much alcohol developed by an MIT
Media Lab researcher the edible gelatin
ice cubes hold a coin cell battery a
microcontroller and a transceiver to
track the number of sips and total time
drinking they flash and sync with
ambient music and change color to
represent the levels of intoxication
aspire Bariatrics has developed a system
that allows people to lose weight by
emptying their stomach with a valve
after a meal aspiration therapy involves
a tube in the stomach connected to a
skin port that can be open to empty
stomach contents before they pass into
the intestines where the calories are
absorbed and then you just dump the
stuff in the toilet so yeah this is a
newfound fossil of a giant dolphin
shaped predator considered to be the
t-rex of the sea vilasa is the second
fastest legged robot clocking in at 3.2
meters per second it moves like a real
cockroach with its legs hitting the
ground 15 times per second and this
cardboard roach can move 26 times its
body length in only one second and also
can carry four times its weight Diego
Sun is a humanoid robot toddler that
combines advancements in robotics
neuroscience compute
vision developmental psychology and
machine learning developed at the
University of California San Diego it
mimics the expressions of a one-year-old
child and the plan is using Studies on
sensory motor and social development
basically how babies learn to control
their bodies and interact with others
the power loader power amplification
exoskeleton robot is being developed by
Panasonic subsidiary actively it's a
full-body exoskeleton designed to carry
over 220 pounds and they hope to use a
more compact version for use in the
reconstruction of the Fukushima Daiichi
nuclear power plant
finally photographer Kat Caprice Cova
took 7,000 and 100 photos in 730 hours
to create this time lapse compilation of
22 flowers
[Music]
I'm gonna leave you with a disco clam a
type of clam that produces its own light
show and as always thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]